this is wat Smith with reason TV now i'm
a comedian so I'm obviously hilarious
but I just landed in LAX and I've got an
audition 17 miles away in Burbank I
don't have a car so how am I going to
get there I'm going to take la's transit
system and hopefully I can get there
faster than I can run it
it's all part of our plan to give
Angelenos the 21st century
transportation system they deserve here
we go we're getting on the train we're
at the train rush hour totally packed
that all we are swiftly and boldly
heading to our destination big windows
no traffic violations we're almost going
as fast as these cars let's see what
some other people think of the train I
love it cheaper than a car yeah faster
than a car just about
just about you trainees faster than bus
Nathan minutes minutes only I'd like the
boss yeah they took a lot of buses off
the line i get for the i guess because
of the gasoline so expensive you know
but we're all suffering because of the
bus the bus service they should have
express trains to go nice from a real
express train you know like to have the
rapid buses you just have a rapid train
to just make a few stops to get downtown
and that would be wonderful if we get
the express trains acuity from South
Central so how long does that take
almost three hours what do you have to
do it's like two trains in no three
trains in two buses you drive 20 minutes
wait 20 minutes drive 20 minutes wait 20
minutes yeah basically 16 miles in four
to six hours yeah I think you could run
faster nah i leaked out in on google
maps it's 20 a week
cool and are you satisfied with that
yeah because that happened time I don't
pay for it my boyfriend does so yeah I'm
satisfied all right we're in a little
bit of a hurry but you know what we made
it this far now we're going to the red
line is this train usually pretty full
at this time it is but this is rush hour
but usually I have no problem getting
the sheet so it's less packed on these
trains than it is in Montreal yeah for
sure it's there's nobody here and this
is rush hour it is it how would you
improve the LA transit system if you
could
make buses
some people have to wait for a long long
time most buses don't run on time so
that makes people II and I would be mad
if I was late we're here at beautiful
universal city the journey is over I'm
gonna make it in time for my audition
and I got enough time for some coffee
and a croissant before I oh wait I got
to take another bus do you think the bus
and the rails make traffic lighter I
think so I mean the blue line has a ton
of people on in the morning and I
imagine those people will be driving so
yeah I mean if it takes you know a few
thousand people off the road you know
every morning I mean I assume that would
help right so I'll be honest the commute
it was pretty tiring and it was pretty
long I had to do a lot of connecting
stops but I finally made it and it only
cost me five bucks now i hope i get this
audition
so Bert's out is flying compared to the
metro what's your commute did you get my
last tweet uh what's your favorite kind
of bread I think a Hawks coming